hello everybody
welcome to our session modernized legacy
java application with anthos
uh i'm harish jayakumar i lead the
application modernization solutions team
and today along with me for this talk i
have amir
hello everybody my name is amir abbas i
am a solutions architect out of san
francisco
thanks amir so quick
guidelines uh all these slides that
we'll be sharing today and all the
information is google confidential
proprietary
shared under nda so please be careful
what you share and how you use them
with that let's get started so when we
talk with customers and any c-level
executives they all have a digital
initiative in the organization but the
problem with executing those initiatives
is that a lot of legacy systems that
hinder the business agility
while consuming majority of the id spend
when we talk about
this majority of id spend they talk
about legacy applications
like java and dot-net applications which
is based on very very tightly coupled
architectures and messy integrations
and these legacy systems therefore
inhibit achieving any cost efficiencies
across the board
across managing these legacy
applications in new applications
maintaining security and compliance
requirements
and ensuring quality of service to the
customer and reliable solutions
as well as it's also going to prevent
them from the agility and shipping new
features to their customers as well
so modernizing java systems is a
priority for many enterprise customers
so as you can see from the statistics
over here we've seen that more than 80
of companies are saying they're going to
continue to leverage the past
investments
in java applications and 40 of the
companies will modify these legacy java
apps
for cloud migration 79 will modernize
java apps with cloud native technologies
with containers and kubernetes as well
so as you can see java clearly dominates
when it comes to deploying application
in production environments and that's
going to be the focus of the talk today
so but what are the challenges in
modernizing these legacy java
applications
first off relay is not a viable option
for many workloads yes you might want to
take and rewrite all these applications
but think about a company that has
hundreds and thousands of legacy
applications
it becomes really really complicated
sometimes these applications are so old
but they don't even have access to the
source code or the developers who
actually wrote those applications are no
longer here
second thing is yeah the question i get
asked is well why can't we just lift and
shift vms
sure it's a safe bet but there are a lot
of those benefits from the new
technologies that not only able to get
and there's also significant cost
increase due to lack of density per host
and years
and then finally the thing that i tell
the customers is that most importantly
we don't see app
organization as a binary problem even if
you can get
if you can't get all the benefits
customers are like can i get some of the
benefits and that's what i talk about
when we say
meeting the customers where they are
depending on your risk of portfolio
depending on the application portfolio
we have choices to take them anywhere
that they want
which brings us to what is google's
point of view when it comes to
modernization it basically is the future
of applications
and the infrastructure that they run on
is created with containerized micro
services
managed through a declarative system
declarative system is where
you know code represents the final state
so kubernetes is a perfect example
with a single control experience that
uses the service mesh
to span all the applicable locations so
service mesh as you know
is a configurable low latency
infrastructure that ensures
communication among these containers
applications so
now that you have these applications
running as containers you want to be
ensuring that there's mutual tls between
them you get all those components right
out of the box
using service mesh to span all
applicable locations on that
and how do we take all of that that we
want to achieve with modernization
you put it into a solution which is
called as anthos so anthos is a managed
application platform that's based on
kubernetes sdmk native
for enterprises that want faster
modernization right and we talk about
this what a talk for sa
tools to perform no touch migration and
greater consistency
in a hybrid and multi-cloud world
so when we talk with customers quickly
what happens is we first
work with them in saying how we can help
them see the business benefits that they
associate the same problem that we
started off first
here's an example of a java landscape
and a software company
as you can see over here the estimated
benefits of a three-year period totally
pays off
in fact even in year one after the
investment in anthos you can see the
licensing cost and support for java
workloads
that they're getting positive as well as
being able to refactor and migration
cost you to modernization as well 80 of
them were due to refactoring of their
java legacy applications and their other
apps as well
but how do we go about doing this it
calls a very
simple three-step process right step one
is we migrate the application as is and
this is where i'm gonna say that it's a
lift
and modernize not a lift and shift
because we're taking the application
and we're converting them to containers
and the business benefit is immediately
in that first step you're able to see
the 37 tco
savings right out of the box now that
you have this as a container you can
actually connect it into an automated
testing and deployment through a ci cd
processor or whatever
and then at your leisure you can
refactor every platform
and as a combination you can see an
extra 78 percent tco savings
so let's start categorizing these apps
not all apps are the same
so when it comes to java application
categories you actually
categorize them into four buckets first
is the applications that are using
modern frameworks these are prime
candidates for containerization
you must have heard of the term
greenfield applications so if your
customers or you are using anything like
web applications
uh you know restful apis spring boot
those are great candidates which we can
quickly take and move them to containers
using dev tools to containerize them
that we have second we have packaged
applications so these are you know
commercial off-the-shelf components
uh maybe you know you don't own the
source code for these applications at
all anymore so you can take this
as well and you can actually use migrate
for amphos and move them to containers
just like i talked about
and the third bucket is brownfield
applications to clarify when i say
brownfield applications
it's not a new application it's not
green field but there is
application that's running it's still
generating revenue and active code is
being checked in and features are being
checked in
these could be in your again monolithic
legacy app servers they have logic web
sphere
these are also great candidates for
migrate for amphos or some of the gsi
tools is another option as well which
i'll talk about a little bit
uh before we move on to focusing on one
of the
one of the options and then finally is
the legacy back-end apps
it's totally cool you don't need to take
them and move all the application to
containers you're going to have some
things that you just want to leave them
either running them
on your vmware or your virtualization
environment
or you can use them connecting with
apigee but with anthony's you can still
manage vms as well
so as you take those four buckets you
can see that you've actually categorized
them into these four
uh separate paths on this and that's why
uh customers would like to when we talk
like this prescriptive approach
depending upon the type of application
and there's a prescriptive path
for the first case if it's like just out
of the you know the new green field
applications easy to containerize them
connect them to a ci cd
and then take them to uh run them on
anthos the second one is
if you're able to take them like i said
uh you know cos applications so you
don't have the source code containerized
with migrate for rentals again run them
on
and then pull them and run them on antos
and then the third one is any business
critical applications the brownfield
applications we talked about we could
use our gsi tools or migrate
to uh migrate parenthose or migrate for
vms as well and then finally extreme
legacy but as you can see
all these lead to and pause where you
can manage and maintain them
and then you can refactor and
re-platform that microservices at your
leisure that same
three-step process that i talked about
before with the savings
so from google cloud we are recommending
for those three
four four four buckets three options for
you to modernize these java applications
option one which will be the focus of
this talk will be more
we'll be going into detail it's
basically how to lift and modernize
these application to containers using
migrate for antos
like i said is a great candidate when
you don't have access to source code
option two is brownfield applications
with proprietary framework so for
example we've actually partnered with
some gsi tools
where we can help you take your code we
look at the code
strip out the commercial component
insert open source components and
generate a github repo
which you can then connect to uh your
cic
pipeline and get all the benefits that
you want and then finally is the
refactoring platform options
out of google cloud we have tons of
frameworks and tons of tools to help you
be able to refactor and rewrite them as
containers with springboard frameworks
as well
but for today's talk we're going to be
just focusing on the migrate for amtha
solution
so migrate for amthos allows you to move
your vms directly into containers
uh right out of the box right because it
offers the customers a way to migrate
the workloads whether you're running
your
them on vms or bare metal this provides
a low friction path for any existing
workloads quickly to move to anthos and
provides the accelerated
migration as well and the modernization
files to additional cloud services
so what are good candidates to be able
to migrate as well
so any web application server or or
business logic applications
middleware based right out of the box
you can easily do that take them and
move them to
using migrate for amthos from a workload
perspective low duty cycles and bursty
workloads are great candidates as well
some of them just use them for training
or labs but you can also run them in
production as well
and then also like middleware frameworks
will be talked about tomcat webs we are
great candidates for you to be able to
use with microphone thus
basically applications that are built on
enterprise links are great candidates
that you can quickly jump in
wherever it's been running on now that
you've taken these applications and this
is where i talk about
bridging the traditional and the modern
one you take these applications you
follow those four paths and you run them
on antos
now you can start using the components
that come with amp which is antho
service mesh that can provide you a sim
uh provider service management and a
single pane of glass for managing your
metrics service identity
and traffic management purposes and also
anthony's config management as well
which is another piece
that comes with enterprise that allows
you to automate your policy and
configuration at scale
so if you want to be able to synchronize
your configuration across multiple
clusters whether it's on-prem on the
cloud
this allows you to uh this allows you to
uh make sure you do that
because it's also based of git so it
enables auditability and review of ci
through policy as code
so let's put all these things together
right we talked about service mesh we
talked about configuration management
and running these applications
so on jke so out of the box you can take
this and that's what antos comes
with migrate for anthony to move these
applications and run them and manage
these
independent of where you're running it
below whether it's and whether it's
going to be on google cloud
on-prem or hypervisor aws wherever it is
so how does it work very quickly we
identify the workloads
um whether it's running on vms or
on-prem
and then migrate for ampers once we've
identified the workloads
we take them and we auto containerize
them and then now you actually
generate the ci cd artifacts that you
need so basically migrate for enthus
basically generates a kubernetes yaml
file
and a docker image and a docker file
which you can then take
and actually move them into antarctics
or connect them to a ci cd pipeline
and now once you're running it on
antarctic like i talked about you can
use all the service mesh
and logging and capabilities as well the
key part
uh the key uh two important things over
here to remember is it's not a lift and
ship you're not completely taking
everything
and simply just moving it into a docker
container
you can see the things in red kernel
drivers management agent logs
things that do not matter you're not
actually taking them and moving them
into the docker into the container world
as well
another key important thing which is
that it also handles
uh persistent workloads so as most of
you know for example if you're running
say your application
on vmware and talking to a say vsan once
you migrated it to anthos
it actually converts them to persistent
volume so right out of the box you're
already in the community's ecosystem and
how to be able to go use that
so it becomes easy for you to run on
those and get all the benefits like our
back honestly
everything right out of the box so now
that i've done the really really hard
work of clicking through slides
i'm going to hand over to amir to do the
demo
i'm here thank you harish
so in this demo we are going to take a
monolithic java application
running as a vm use migrate for anthos
to convert that vm into a container
and then run that containerized
application onto the anthos platform
so here i am in my vcenter console and
you can see that i have a vm called java
dash
app now this is a rel7 app here's the ip
address
and if we go to that ip address you can
see that it's backed by a web logic
server it's a single admin server and we
can also go to the front end now this is
a
sample app called hipster shop it's kind
of simulating an e-commerce experience
and you can see from the looks of it
it's looking fairly antiquated
and it's probably been stuck this way
because it's quite painstaking to change
anything in a monolithic application
so let's take this application as is
convert it into a container
using migrate forensics and then run
that container onto the anthos platform
and then over time we also want to see
how can the anthos platform
benefit this application as it gets
refactored into microservices
so let's go into the gcp console here i
am in my kubernetes clusters page and
you can see that i have three kubernetes
clusters
i have a devus west 2 cluster
representing my dev environment
and a prod us west 2 cluster
representing my production environment
we're going to take that containerize
application and run it onto the dev
cluster
we also have this third cluster called
m4a processing now this is the migrate
for antos
processing cluster now it's running the
migrate for anthos controller that
connects back to our vmware environment
that i showed you
converts that vm into a container and
also generates all of the kubernetes
artifacts that are required to run that
container into kubernetes
all right great so let's jump into cloud
shell
and first things first let's make sure
that we are connected to
all of our clusters
so you can see that i'm connected to dev
prod and m4a processing
and i'm actually going to run this demo
a little bit backwards i'm actually
going to deploy
the generated artifacts first and then
we're going to go back in time
and then i'll show you how we got to
those generated artifacts and the reason
is because it takes
three to four minutes to get that
application up and running
and i don't want to waste anybody's time
here so for me to deploy it
i'm going to create a brand new
namespace into the dev cluster
so let's call it tipster legacy crm aaa
and then i'm going to deploy the
generated artifacts which are inside of
a file called deployment spec
yaml inside of the hipster legacy crm
aaa namespace
okay great so a bunch of things got
deployed we'll take a look at those
later
so now let's connect to our migrate for
anthos processing cluster
now as far as part of migrate for anthos
we have a tool called
mig-ctl that allows us to do
a bunch of things so first things i want
to see which sources am i connected to
now in addition to vmware we can also
connect to gce instances or aws ec2
instances
in this case i'm just connected to my
single vmware instance
now migration plans are stored as yaml
files
if we look at the list of files in this
folder you can see that i have a file
called hipster crm migration demo yaml
and if we inspect that file this is the
migration plan it looks a lot like a
kubernetes yaml file
and you can see a few things for example
i'm migrating both the image and the
data remember it's a weblogic server
here's my vmid java dash app
if we scroll further down you can see
exclude filters these are the folders i
do not want migrated as part of my
containerized app so things like swap
files or boot folders or temp folder
right below that is my image information
the containerized image gets stored into
a gcr registry and here's the name of
that image
right below that is information about
data
so here's the persistent volume claim
that it's going to store that data in
and here is the folder inside of the vm
the db folder that it's going to convert
that data from
right below that is the bucket where the
generated artifacts are going to get
stored
and here's the name of the bucket where
we're going to store that
and then right at the end we have the
application name that it's going to run
in kubernetes as which is hipster legacy
ccrm
okay great so let's go ahead and
generate
this plan so i'm going to again use
the mix ctl command migration generate
artifacts and i'm going to run that
that plan now at this point it's
connecting back to my vmware environment
containerizing that application and then
generating all of the kubernetes
resources
and then those resources are stored into
it that gcs bucket
so now that it's done let's look at that
gcs bucket
and see what got generated so you can
see that we have the docker file
and then we also have that deployment
spec yaml and this was the yaml file
that i deployed at the very beginning of
the demo
so let's go ahead and inspect that
deployment spec
and if you're familiar with kubernetes
this is a plain old vanilla kubernetes
ammo so
since this is a stateful application
it's created a stateful set
it can also create deployments if this
was not a stateful app
it's also created a service
with a service type load balancer so
it's going to expose this service with
an external load balancer on port 7001
and then right below that it's created a
persistent volume claim
for the data and then lastly it's also
created a persistent volume
with a gce persistent disk that's where
all the data is going to get stored so
those were the four resources that it
got deployed onto the dev cluster
so let's connect to the dev cluster
and let's change our namespace to the
hipster legacy crm aaa namespace
and let's look at the pods inside of
that namespace
great so you can see that we have this
hipster legacy crm
stateful set with a single pod running
and remember as part of that
we also created a service called hipster
legacy crm
and it's exposed with an external ip
address
and it's exposed on port 7001 so if we
take that ip address
and if we go to the front end of that ip
address
which happens to be at this url
you can see that it's looking exactly
the same the only difference is now this
application is running as a
containerized application
on kubernetes in the atos platform
versus a virtual machine in vmware
so very easily we were able to use
migrate for enthos not
do any kind of recoding or rewriting and
convert this application into a
container
and then generate the artifacts that are
needed to run this
onto kubernetes now over time
we have refactored this application into
a set of microservices and
run this on the production cluster so
here i am in my workloads page
and i'm filtered filtering this page by
the produce west 2 cluster
and previously what was known as the
hipster shop has now been face lifted
and now it's called the online boutique
shop
and you can see that it's got a number
of microservices like ad
cards checkout currency and so on and if
we go to the services page for that
application
you can see all of the services for
every single microservice as well as
this front end
that's exposed on a public ip address
so we can navigate to that ip address
and hopefully
you can see the kind of the new and
improved experience of what was
previously known as the
hipster shop now known as the online
boutique
it's an e-commerce experience i can
perform
do some shopping here i can buy some
vintage typewriters
these are all different services like
cart service checkout service i can
place the order using the checkout
service
all of those microservices are working
together to give us this application
experience
now part of anthos is what we're trying
to do is bring
google sre best practices to our
customers that are using the anthos
platform
so here if i go to the anthos service
mesh page
we are powering this application by the
service mesh
and right off the bat we get a lot of
observability and security posture
information so we get
all of our services that are running
note we also get the legacy crm
application that we converted we get the
status
health status of those applications so
some status some
applications are healthy some are not we
get the type of applications which
clusters they're running in but also
metrics like requests per second error
and latency
we also get topology information for
that application so if we go into the
topology page you can actually see how
requests are traversing
we can see the legacy one which just has
a simple load generator it's going
straight into the legacy crm app
but we also see the micro services based
online boutique app which has
the front end and it's talking to a lot
of different microservices
and if we hover over each any of these
microservices we get
additional information like queries per
second and so on
we also get health status of each of
these services right on the topology
page so recommendation service is
healthy
but check out service is not so if we go
to the checkout service
we can delve deeper into an individual
service
so now i'm in the checkout service and
we can see what's going on with this
service
so up top we have a timeline of the
health status of that service
and right now it's set to one hour time
span and you can see that it's
definitely been unhealthy for the last
hour
let's check it for one day i want to see
when did it start becoming unhealthy
so you can see that yesterday around 3
30 p.m
is when it started becoming unhealthy
and what does that mean that it was
unhealthy
well we've created some service level
objectives for this particular service
so here's the slo if i go into the slo
details page i've created a single slo
it's a latency based slo you can create
one or more slos per service
let's edit this slo and let's start at
the beginning on what that even means so
the first thing i want to do is i want
to select my
service level indicator it could either
be availability based latency based or
even a custom metric space in this case
we're doing a latency based
indicator and it's a request-based slo
we go to the next screen i've set my
latency threshold to two seconds for the
95th percentile
percentile latency so i'd like my 95th
percentile latency to be two
seconds or less or lower and you can see
from the historical data that it's been
creeping up
over time all the way up to eight nine
ten seconds
no wonder it's acting unhealthy here i
can set the compliance period for
a single day for example i'd like 75
of the time to be within that service
level objective which is
that i would like my 95th percentile to
be 2 seconds or less
75 of the time and obviously we are not
meeting that
and that's why it's unhealthy you can
also set alerts
that gets fired as it becomes unhealthy
we can also get into further metrics
which particular deployment is causing
that so in this case
i can break this down by location it
could be a single region or a single
cluster or a
specific instance of that cluster i can
go very granular
into figuring out exactly what's causing
that problem and then go and mitigate
that problem in this case we're just
running it into a single prod cluster
in one pod but let's say this
application was running on multiple
clusters in multiple regions
you can start to now drill this down and
troubleshoot it
speaking of security postures if i go to
connected services
for the checkout service i can see both
requests coming in
and out of that service so i can see who
is talking to that service and who
does that service talk to so i'm in the
inbound request page and i can see that
i'm only receiving requests from the
front down
front end service and i can also see the
security posture which is this green
lock representing that this traffic is
encrypted using mtls
similarly i can go to the outbound and
you can see a ton of other services that
it talks to
and every single one of these services i
can see the port as well as the security
posture
where it's all encrypted so hopefully
this gave you an idea of how we can take
a monolithic virtual machine
use migrate forensics to convert it into
a container and run it onto kubernetes
and then over time as we refactor this
application into microservices
we can use anthos service mesh to
implement some of the google sre best
practices
into your platform all right so let's
recap real quick so the first thing we
identified the vm
running in virtual machine that's on the
left hand side we took a weblogic server
the first thing we want to do is
migrate it to anthos so uplift the
platform
we did that using migrate for entos we
made the vm much more lightweight by
excluding some of those
uh files and folders that harish talked
about before
and then we deployed that to a staging
cluster inside of gke now we can start
using benefits of asm
and such now sometime later over time
we've
turned that service into a number of
microservices
and at that point we can really start to
get the value of antos service mesh we
can look at the topology
we can get the metrics we can start
setting slos per service
and we can really start to incorporate
some of those sre best practices
so hopefully that gave you an idea of a
life cycle of an application going from
a virtual machine inside vmware all the
way to microservices inside of anthos
back to you harish thanks amir
i know we covered a lot of stuff today
so as next steps i'm going to leave you
with two links which is going to help
you
first is bitly java dash and toss
where you can learn more about how you
could use anthos for your java
modernization journey
and then link two is bitly java
and those dash blog where we're talking
about the steps that we covered today on
how you can go through methodically
to achieve the modernization journey as
well as you will find a link
for a free trial to get started on your
modernization journey with panthos
thank you all for joining today
you